so what I see with this particular
Church which is so impressive is they're
investing in the things that the
congregation are witnessing close up you
know so it's like the
um you know the treasure binding of the
Gospel they've got the icons obviously
and the Chalice you know and then they
got the candelabras and pretty much
that's it or you know they're probably
going to be flowers and their icons are
just on a couple of easels but they've
draped them in some beautiful fabric and
I and again I just love that because
it's economy and its focus and it's
really putting the resources where they
should be and kind of traveling around
in England and going to churches in
other denominations what I see is just
you know in some ways they have more
resources but there isn't the same Focus
you know they might all be fundraising
for the the best free roof or something
which I I know these practical problems
exist and we need to we need to address
them but also it's like but where is the
priority and you know it's I really
wanted to if anyone's listening appeal
to people please engage artists and
designers in your church because design
is happening whether you like it or not
you know I think you've talked about
this Jonathan but you can't avoid design
it's going to work on your congregation
anyway so use it consciously
[Music]
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone I am very happy to be
here with Heather paulington if you've
been following me for a while you've
heard me drop her name a few times
Heather is a designer she has worked on
several projects very large movies that
you've heard about and we've been
collaborating now for several months we
did my whole branding you can see the
great new symbolic World logo the the
symbolic World website uh you know just
beautiful work that that she has
produced for me but I thought it would
be really interesting to discuss with
her and look at her process how she
comes to her ideas to her designs how
she takes a a movie story and is able to
create images and designs and sets based
on that so Heather it's really great to
have you with me today hi thanks for
inviting me and so my first question to
you is how does one end up doing the
things you're doing because it's very
particular
it is very particular
um
studied similar time to you art school
as a fine artist
um and I think pretty quickly I realized
that the sort of contemporary Fine Art
world wasn't really for me and I was
interested in filmmaking process
particularly and I was lucky because at
that time
um in Britain the film world was kind of
exploding because of the Harry Potter
movies and I was lucky enough to get my
kind of entry-level role on the Harry
Potter series and that's where I learned
the craft really it was some of the best
people in the world working at that time
and the sets were very detailed
um and that's really where I started out
and um today I'm just going to take you
through some of the the films I've
worked on
um and kind of how we go about designing
for films and throughout the last 20
years it's been my role has been a sort
of graphic artist graphic designer which
means within the film art Department I'm
responsible for
um anything that has like a graphic
design illustrative element it could be
like a it might be a book it might be
branding within a film you know like
um
sort of branding for a bond villains
company it could be a
um monogram for a medieval ping for
example so it's really varied it depends
what film you're on different periods
and you really have to learn the
language of that film right at the
offset and then you can start creating
things in that language and the
languages are quite complex which you'll
see because from the outset people think
you know it's a medieval film but but
really that could mean hundreds of
different things so you're taking your
cues from the director about what do we
mean what is the world we're creating
and it's always driven by the story
um the story we're trying to tell and
we're setting it within that within that
kind of term so we'll we'll go through
um but first I want to say that before I
show you things
when I discovered your channel like so
much of what you talked about resonated
with me because there's a lot of
similarities to the way that we work in
film I mean we sort of work in in the
symbolic World generally
um and also it's it's a world of visual
hierarchies and so a lot of the stuff
you talked about with hierarchy really
kind of chimed and I'm going to kind of
look at it through that lens because I
thought it'd be interesting for your for
yourself because like you said in some
ways the the idea of making a medieval
film it's not just about making
something medieval is to make it
medieval within the purpose of the story
itself and so the sets and the images
have to supplement or you know help the
story it's not just about showing a
medieval castle right or showing some
medieval tapestry or whatever well well
exactly so you know what is the medical
the world it can be 100 different things
so we have to decide what it is that
we're saying and and I'm going to also
talk about the the difference between
history and story
um what you'll find if you go on IMDb
IMDb you'll have a lot of experts saying
you know this is historically inaccurate
um which in some cases is true and
mistakes get made but quite often people
will purposefully break with history in
order to prioritize story so we're going
to have a look at that as well
um so I'll just should I just share my
screen this is a diagram of the sort of
hierarchy of props on the film set and
I've noticed I've listened to a lot of
discussions that you've heard about
perception and how we sort of experience
the world and how
um you know people that we know or
things we care about will appear to us
in detail
um and things that we maybe aren't aware
of even though they're in front of us we
we don't really see them and actually
that idea is formal in the filmmaking
process so if you go onto a film set we
have a way of categorizing props so hero
prop would be it's held by the actor it
has a specific purpose to tell a story
and it's likely to be in close-up it
might be in close-up with the actor or
it could even be an insert shot where
literally your prop is the whole screen
of the movie and that that hero prop
will contain
um
lots lots of detail for the story it
might be a moment where you suddenly you
know something is revealed in this image
or this prop so it's very important a
lot of time and energy is spent into
getting those things right directors
really care about them because obviously
if they don't work then the you know the
audience doesn't understand what's going
on
um and technically a hero prop will
um it's normally made for real so if
we're making like a medieval book it
will be made properly in leather with
proper
um you know metal work the interior will
be parchment it might be hand painted we
will use real gold leaf that sort of
thing that that level of detail and then
as you go down this hierarchy to the to
what's dressing then background and then
deep background that process kind to an
extent deteriorate so if you're looking
at Deep background props that may be
four meters from the camera really you
it's probably not going to be the real
thing it's going to be something that
looks looks like the real thing you know
we're going to spend a little bit less
attention a little bit a little bit less
time on that thing
um so this is all very important because
when when you have film budgets you
really have to put that money into the
right things that you're getting value
from on screen and yeah you can see how
it's a contraction of our experience
because like you said the problem is
that you have a limited amount of
resources obviously you don't have
infinite resources and just that very
fact and the fact that you have to
you have to create attention with the
limited amount of resources therefore
they'll a hierarchy will immediately get
set up because you you have to decide
what's more important and what's less
important and that will have to do with
attention in terms of of a movie for
sure absolutely because we have very
tight deadlines so we have to decide you
know where are we going to put our
energy and what's going to be seen on
screen and and um you know how the
audience going to read what we're doing
so that's all really inbuilt to our
process and it's interesting because
when you see actually when you think of
movies where the uh resources became
near infinite
um then all of a sudden everything
becomes
flatness to those those movies and those
stories I'm thinking of of how after
Lord of the Rings which was so amazing
Peter Jackson just got like infinite
amount of resources to make King Kong
and then you just you're just like your
eyes are straining to watch King Kong
fight one more dinosaur and and just
like millions of details that won't stop
you know yeah yeah very elaborated
resources forces a proper hierarchy it's
so interesting you say that because it
is a problem and it's something we're
going to kind of find out as we go
through this
um so I would say yeah in the last 10
years there's there's sort of been a
diminishment of hierarchy in film uh two
things as you say unlimited budgets
almost and you know obviously CG which
which is it's kind of Limitless and um
and in a way it's it's compromised the
craft
um and if you watch older films you know
that are more limited technically you'll
see you'll see more
just better storytelling
um
you know it's difficult to describe but
it had to do with hierarchy definitely
because what ends up happening is not
just even in what you're doing it's not
just hierarchy of of objects but it ends
up being a kind of hierarchy of motion
and the hierarchy of of action right you
know in another movie your action scene
costs you so much to make and was so
demanding that you had to really make it
dramatically relevant and dramatically
constructed and now it's like you just
watch CGI characters fight for 15
minutes and it's so boring because
there's no Stakes right there's no
Stakes yeah yeah it's like it's like the
the crew aren't invested and then as a
viewer neither are you yeah
um
anyway so I'm just going to go through
these images so this is um it seems like
stating the obvious but I want to do
that just in case people aren't aware
that most of the films I work on they
really do start like this it's basically
a warehouse
and then and then we build
um
everything so you're gonna build the
walls and then you're gonna get the
interior decoration and then every
single prop is going to be brought into
that space
um this is the bond stage at Pine which
we should I've done a few sets and I
work for an amazing designer called
Dennis gassner and he he was kind of my
mentor earlier on in my career and he
said you know the story has to be in
every single thing that we do so when we
stood there we're
you know we're bringing all these things
in and we we have to decide like you
know if there's
three different knives or three
different logos we have to decide which
one it is and so so our point is which
one is best for the story and and that
applies to everything you know even like
down to the paper choice that I make so
in that case if if I was doing like an
MI6 office for James Bond you know we
even though you're not going to see it
we would still think about the paper
that they that they have in that office
you know that would be a choice and and
it's easier to have those limitations
because like you say otherwise it's just
a million choices
um so so we have that as our as our kind
of guiding rule
um I just want to say as well that all
of these images I produce them in a team
so there's lots of people
um that I've worked with over the years
and um especially my my job share
partner Kathy who's been part of this
process so I just want to mention them
because there's too many to name as I go
through
um so this is
um this is where I started out this is
Harry Potter as you can see in these two
images from the film
um there's a lot of documents and a lot
of books and I started off really doing
very background props and what you need
in that case is a lot of quantity and a
lot of texture so as I was explaining
before
um how we deal with props in terms of a
hierarchy you can see on the image in
the right where Harry is that here you
have real books
um and then here which is a few minutes
away from the camera these are fake and
and I spent about six months of my
career at the beginning just making
these books and you can't open them so
um but again they totally serve the
purpose we had to fill the whole library
with hundreds of books so
um you start off doing that when you're
when you're at the bottom and then in
about two thousand seven I got a lucky
break and went out to Budapest to work
for Yama Del Toro and Hellboy II and at
that point I was running the department
and that then I'm responsible for all
all the graphic props so
um the you know everything from the hero
things like these where you've got Maps
storytelling Maps
um and then you know also I'm doing
background things but the background
things do have a lot of detail so for
example this is like this was the um the
map room in in this kind of underground
realm called The Troll market and we had
to develop a language for that world and
then all of these little tags that you
see they have the troll language stamped
on them
um and all of these Maps
um me and my assistant Alex we drew all
of those Maps they're just hanging in
the background but they're all our own
work so you can see just the amount of
detail that goes in
um and people you know people think well
why would you do that why why not just
go and get any old map
um but in this case you know if you're
in a fantasy world you can't you can't
get anything from The Real World so
you've got you've got really got to make
it
um and it's so funny that you know for
people the people watching you know when
Heather contacted me and she said that
she had made these props on Hellboy 2 I
specifically remember watching Hellboy 2
and and being and and realizing the
difference between Hellboy 2 and a lot
of the other movies that I'd seen in
terms of the attention to detail and
also at the time I was already
interested in medieval uh like
Aesthetics and more ancient Aesthetics
and I thought like oh they got this
right like they got so many things right
in terms of in terms of that so so uh so
I have to say I want to tell everybody I
mean if you haven't seen Hellboy 2 just
visually just for the visuals it is it
is worth watching it's pretty astounding
um it's like yeah what this is one of
the hero props from Hellboy 2 and this
you know pretty much
you know early in my career I've been
given this was pretty amazing because
um it's right in the first scene and
Professor broom has this book and it
basically introduces the whole world of
the Golden Army and they use it as a
portal for an animation so it's in close
up so this is one of the examples this
is my visual uh which I just drew in a
computer on the left
um but then it did you know get made uh
by some bookbinders and Budapest and
leather and everything
um and I think
it was interesting because I knew we
were sort of in the medieval world but
you can tell by looking at it you know
the colors are pretty lurid it's
definitely in the world of fantasy it's
got a robot in the middle
um but it's it's something some really
valuable thing that I learned from
Guillermo was about kind of style and
color you know one thing he said was
Hellboy is red and therefore everything
in the movie is pretty much green and
and blue and because you always want
Hellboy to be the focus so again just to
explain that what I do is never like
about an individual object or me it's
always complementary it's always part of
the the drama that we're creating and so
you have to have all those
considerations in place when you're
designing stuff
um but there's such a there's such a
sensibility go back to the the one
before like this if you look at the
little tree that you designed there on
the left the the little kind of uh
symbolic tree there I mean it has it
really has
it has a an understanding of how to make
a symbolic tree but it doesn't look like
any other one that I've seen before and
so that's why it it really works in
terms of a fantasy movie that's also
related you know it's like it's related
to to our history because it it's as if
there's a secret history kind of going
through our normal history and that's
what it feels like when you see it it's
like oh that's a obviously that's like a
tree that I could see in an old design
or like Islamic Art I'm not sure but it
it looks like that but it's not quite
that it's interesting you
from that because I actually didn't
go and I think it was it was a it was a
piece from the concept art that I had to
integrate so that can happen quite a lot
again this this process is massively
collaborative
um and you know there's a lot of people
involved so sometimes you'll get given
something so I that was the only thing I
got and then I developed the book around
it like you say there was already a good
language in there that I could use and
kind of extend out
um but you can see there the lettering
around the outside that's like a kind of
bespoke alphabet that we developed in
our department
um
so so these are um yeah some of the
other bits and Bobs from Hellboy tea
that I did
um you can see there's quite a few here
there's a lot of hero props in that in
that film
um this one you know it's just an
incidental Hotel sign
um where this creature kind of rips off
the Earth so it can be something as
boring as that that you have to design
and here you can see Hellboy stood in
front of a it's it was supposed to be
under Brooklyn Bridge and we built the
whole thing in Budapest
um and we had to do all the storefronts
so again you're kind of you're trying to
um reference like contemporary New York
but at the same time you know you're in
the comic book world so everything is
like exaggerated oversized I did this
you I don't know if you can see it I did
like Daddy-O's garage because we were
referencing like sort of 50s comic book
Americana so yeah it's it's really a
world of its own and you have to
um really get into that and and think
you know beyond the script really yeah
um so after that I did
um a couple of the Bond films and and
these are these are kind of interesting
because
um you might look at this image and
think you know it's pretty boring but
it's actually one of the most
interesting films and the reason is
um we're working with Sam Mendes he was
he was telling a story about London in
2012.
MI6 got blown up and the MI6 team went
into a bunker so what he's doing there
is he's tapping into something for the
the kind of at least the British
audience you know about the second world
war
um it's it's The Narrative of kind of
you know Bond being out of date you know
so when I talked to him about what does
this office look like he wanted me to
produce this file here
and and it's purposefully very
kind of old-fashioned it's almost 1990s
you know we're in 2012 the likelihood is
things would be digital but again you
would select in terms of story that you
would go towards the old-fashioned
towards the manual in order to create a
certain narrative about the world that
Bonds in
um and what I'm seeing at the moment in
film and I don't know about you Jonathan
but particularly in medieval films
there's just constant Innovation
um people always want to do something
new visually and the problem is
sometimes we need to be conservative in
design and now in the case of Skyfall he
is in London and you see you see the
world that he's in in MI6 and then he
travels to Shanghai yeah and this is a
an animated jellyfish that he encounters
and there's a fight scene so compared to
the world we've come from this world is
very technologically advanced it's
alienating it's strange you've got this
blue light and so what Sam's doing is
he's got these two contrasts
um but what I'm seeing is when when
people want to inject kind of strange
elements everywhere
that's kind of falling away so I'll give
you an example if you saw um if you saw
the the Green Knight film yeah so that
film there was a lot that I admired
about the design I thought it was really
interesting but after I'd finished
watching it I was like there's something
about that film that I can't figure out
that didn't didn't quite work for me and
I was reading Gawain in the green night
with my daughter and it was just like an
old 70s book with watercolors and it
started off saying
um you know the opening thing was like
we're in Camelot you know every everyone
sat around the fire okay you're in the
home state and then suddenly like this
this Green Knight comes in on Horseback
which is completely strange right and so
there's a dramatic impact there because
you have a conservative setting that is
home and then the strangers comes into
that yeah but the problem with that film
is that the setting of the round
there was a globalist element to it so
as we went in I was like wow some you
know these visuals are stunning
but when the Green Knight came in it
just felt like more of the same so I
feel like it's something that that is
there and I just wanted to to show when
it's done well it really does work in
terms of story and and this is something
that I when I talk to people who go to
films they don't necessarily they can't
really articulate what the problem is
but they know if something just didn't
quite work or they they're just like oh
you know I don't really get the story or
whatever so yeah it just didn't land you
asked the person you know if why didn't
you like it or did you like it and they
don't know why they just know that
they're usually yeah they usually just
say well you know yeah
it wasn't that great or whatever but but
I'm seeing more and more now I'm aware
of this thing it's one of the reasons
why that people people need to be
restrained sometimes I think
um in terms of how much they're
innovating yeah I know when I when I see
the two images you showed the one the
one of MI6 and the bunker then I
realized that using arches you know
because you wouldn't have you wouldn't
have had to use arches but using arches
and and brick and you know kind of that
that that aesthetic is perfect for the
contrast with with this kind of
high-tech world
yeah and it does it not only does it
look like a bunker but it looks it looks
old like it looks like a like an old
basement from uh you know a 17th century
building or something yeah and it it's
built you know again that's not a
location that was all done purposefully
it's it was really clever yeah
um
so I'm just kind of made this point
about the Primacy of story of reality
and I just wanted to share
um this example with you and a lady that
does the same job as me called Annie
Atkins she's got a great Instagram and
she pulled up this um example
um and it's it it refers to Titanic so
when Rose arrives in New York on a
Lifeboat she looks out at a green Statue
of Liberty in 1912 the statue would have
not been fully oxidized and should have
been a copper color and she and she she
shows the um this postcard from 1912 but
yeah
so so if the director showed a copper
Statue of Liberty the the audience would
would go why is that brown yeah because
their frame of reference is that it's
green whereas if it's green what the
audience feels is home you know or
America or what you know whatever it is
so
that that's what we want we're always
going for the emotion with the audience
and you know small historical details
like that although it will annoy people
it's it's less important when you're
making a film
yeah it's a great example to help you
understand like you said the Primacy of
story and you know people will get
annoyed maybe with me but I think that's
something that happens in traditional
stories all the time and even possibly
in the Bible story that is especially
with time certain details get get
contracted in a manner to make sure that
they that they communicate to the
largest
amount of people what has to be
communicated and so that there's a
there's a need to because if it if that
doesn't happen then idiosyncrasy is
idiosyncrasy and you've you know you you
don't have the same level of it same
kind of attention to something strange
and you do asyncratic than you do to
something like you said that feels
familiar and so the example of the
statue is a great one to help people
understand yeah it's really good and
you're absolutely right so um we're
gonna get onto some medieval things in a
minute but
um what I would say is you know say say
you're doing a medieval film you can
only really use examples that are going
to be within within the experience of
your audience because if if you pull
something up from the 13th century that
is no longer recognized
it's not going to work like no one knows
what that is and like you say it's
jarring because they're like well you
know what's that thing in the background
so yeah unless that's what you want to
do unless you want to create uh
otherworldly
another worldly effect like that's what
I I keep thinking about it if I made a
film in the Middle Ages I would I would
write it and I would make it in a way
that would make the the Middle Ages look
like almost like uh how can I say this
like a paradise right which would be
surprising to be because they're used to
make to making it look like dirty
disgusting you know uh place and so it's
like that that surprise would be used in
the story it's like why why is
everything so like gold and colorful and
and you know so that but you would have
to put it in the story if it's just
background it's not worth it it's not
worth the effort definitely not I mean
we've talked about that haven't we the
kind of recent trend for making
everything in the Medieval World kind of
brown and
but I've kind of pondered on why that is
and this is my country about it
I think it's to do with you know the
Western world's slight
um discomfort with its past and
particularly it's Christian past because
what I've seen on set is if there's
something like a prop that people are
not pleased with they'll get a prop guy
to come and and spray brown over it it's
how I've seen it happen loads of times
they go I'll just dirty that down
because they just want it to kind of to
fade into the background Fade Into the
background exactly and what you see now
in in medieval films is that that's
happening on mass that the whole thing
has gone Brown and it's like you know if
you look at like heraldic language for
example is so brightly colored and
Powerful you know and that's how it
would have been in the medieval world
I'm talking now about historical actions
yeah yeah and so but the effect like it
would be interesting because the effect
of working with the saint Chapel I was
there you know in Paris this uh a few
weeks ago with my kids and they've never
been you know they've never seen it and
I was like getting them all I was
getting ready to watch their eyes when
they would walk into the church and just
see the red and the blue and the gold
and just you know all the it's just so
it's just so overwhelming and so you
know it's interesting it'd be
interesting to think of that
dramatically in terms of uh in terms of
Storytelling like how how could we
change people's perception of the Middle
Ages in the story by creating that same
surprise that you have when you walk
into oh definitely I've I've thought
about that many times
um okay I'm gonna carry on yeah so this
would this is like a hero prop for Mary
Poppins so this is just an example from
my work of the amount of things that you
might have to think about if you're
creating something like this so story is
here and the Banks family have a
certificate
um and even though Mary Poppins returns
is set in the 1930s the certificate
dates back to the 1910 1910 even and so
I had to create this so basically
looking at
um design of certificates and then you
have to go into the whole history of the
banking industry where would it have
been based when would it have been
established what was the currency at the
time figuring out the address and all
the details signatories things like that
as well as looking at the typography so
even though it's just a bit of ephemera
in a film yeah again if it's wrong if
you're aware that people are going to
kind of you know screen grab it on the
internet and then go on IMDb and tell
you where you're wrong and yes
but this is this was the world of
um Mary Poppins
um returns that I worked on and I put
this in because again it's it's not just
about um worlds that you create in this
case is definitely about memory it's
like you're dealing with a very iconic
character that is very precious to lots
of people uh so when you come onto a
film like this it's not like oh you know
amazing creative opportunities although
they may come it's more I have a huge
responsibility to kind of preserve
um this this world and you know so that
the people who love it you know don't
get disappointed so
um we're looking at 1930s London here
but it's all definitely through the lens
of the the world of Mary Poppins so you
can see
um you know lots of pastel colors it's
it's it's
um
it's it's pretty light you know these I
had to replicate these um blocks these
iconic blocks from the first movie
um
and then this in that film was the world
of the villain which was in the bank
so it was like Bank signage carpets
um account Ledger and there's the
certificate there kind of set within the
Mary Poppins kite and that's part of the
story there
um
and so to the
Medieval World we were just talking
about so this is a classic example it's
um Maleficent too
um and I was really pleased to be
um asked to do this film because the
designer wanted to do a brightly colored
version of the Medieval World that was
very much referencing
um the world of Disney and I absolutely
love early Disney I love the the
Sleeping Beauty from 1959
um so obviously you look you're looking
at the Original Sleeping Beauty cartoon
but because I have to make uh like real
world examples my Approach was right I'm
going to go into medieval art kind of
late Gothic
um
maybe kind of 14 15th century and I'm
going to try and find examples of of
Disney and on the right hand side here
you can see just a couple of my
references and and you know it's
interesting to see that they do exist
um you know this image here which is
from 1470 you know it could be from an
animation it's it's so stylized so
you're looking for overlaps there that
are going to kind of
um
you know tick boxes in both worlds if
you like
this is um
Michelle Pfeiffer in front of one of my
tapestries so this would be a example of
a deep background prop you're never
gonna see it up close she's about four
meters away from it
um and it's complementing the drama
she's here
um like practicing her crossbow shot and
so what we've got in the background is
um I did about 12 of them a tapestry
where
um a mythical creatures having its horn
removed and some of the others were like
mythical creatures being killed that was
the narrative that she was Waging War on
the mythical world yeah yeah so you're
going to use color like obviously you've
got the red that's really obvious and
you've got the
um the unicorn with its horn snapped and
then I use for this in this case quite a
graphic style of tapestry that was a bit
earlier
um than the 15th century because I knew
it was deep background and if it was
going to register in any way it needed
to be
um you know quite graphic and obvious
yeah and it reads I mean I think that it
for people it also reads so right
because we most people that have seen
medieval art have seen the the Unicorn
tapestries that you know that exist that
some I think some are in New York and
then somewhere yeah I looked at those
yeah definitely
yeah it's interesting because I read
about the original animators at Disney
and they all went to look at those
tapestries oh yeah so they based the
animation on this tapestries and then I
was here designing tapestries that were
referencing the animation so there is a
kind of a nice kind of circular
connection there
um but yeah the other thing to consider
is the costume you know she's there in a
white dress so if I'd done a light
tapestry it wouldn't work so I have to
do something where you know it's going
to
complement what she's wearing
um this is a set from Maleficent two
this is
um with studio lights on so this is how
you'll never see it in the film but I'm
I'm showing it you like this so you can
see all the details so basically my
department would be responsible for this
huge carpet and 40 foot uh kind of
Persian style heraldic carpet
we were doing Flags we were doing
banners we're doing chair backs
um plates all sorts it was like a
banqueting sequence so we would
um have all these elements made bespoke
um for the sets
um and this is a close-up of the carpet
so
um you know
a car if something's on the floor it's
not just deep background it's not even
on the same plane as your camera really
right your camera's going this way and
the carpets here so a lot of people are
just say you know it doesn't matter just
you know do something do something quick
and easy and but I really wanted to draw
this as a bit of a challenge so I do
this in a computer we printed it on onto
velvets
um and I think at this point you're
really creating something for the crew
and the actors it's like I said it's
it's not really going to register on
screen but what what's lovely is if
actors and crew come on to us there and
they see the amount of effort that
different departments have put in you
know to different things and
um you know it's it's good for the
project if if people invest time in
detail I think
so the idea is that the animals are all
being caught like they're all changing
yeah yeah that's right
um yeah so yeah sorry this um I use the
heraldic language because we we're in a
kind of public space and we wanted we
wanted to make the point that you know
in the narrative the queen is kind of
capturing the mythical creatures
Maleficent comes in and it's supposed to
be a quite a hostile environment so
um I was depicting these animals you
know with chains which again is is kind
of we've seen all this in in heraldry so
again you kind of Select from heraldry
the thing that suits your story
um and uh I'll zoom in on it if I can
you can just see
oh yeah like how many how many little
pieces there
um
so
and this is this is the scene with that
carpet so you can see really how much
he's registering not not much yeah you
know the other element of what we do is
you can make something and then the
lighting department come along and you
know completely change the way that
something looks um
but you know it's I still really enjoy
doing it and it was it was a great thing
to draw yeah like you said the the the
energy and the the basic the basic
effort reads you know it you can you can
feel the richness of the of the texture
and the space so
it definitely adds
the picture of me with another tapestry
from that film so we're in a
um
in a bedroom space so it's more intimate
it's you I went for a bit of a softer
language because I knew
um you know like I said it's more
private it's more likely that the actors
may be closer
um and you can see that that's it hung
on the wall it's obviously supposed to
be like a heavyweight tapestry but you
can see from that shot that it's just a
piece of white fabric with a digital
print yeah
so um what I have to do in this case is
actually draw
I have to put everything into the
artwork because the technology of How
It's produced is not going to give me
anything
um and one of the most important things
that I've learned doing this kind of
work is how much technology
um
defines art and I think when I was like
a fine artist I used to think that
they're artists with everything and you
know you could just make whatever you
wanted but things like tapestries
um are so driven by the technology so
when I was drawing this I had to
consider where to look into
you know what what were the limitations
of the dyes for example you know if if
you think about the red tapestry I
showed you before that's earlier it's
probably because they had like more
basic looms they had like thicker wool
you know so the actual
um the actual language was had to be
kind of simpler and more graphic and
then as you got to like the late 15th
century things were more sophisticated
um and so so you got like finer finer
details finer illustration but they
still only had like you know x amount of
colors available and the challenge for
someone like me who's working on a
computer is again just having infinite
colors you know it's a problem you have
you have to limit yourself in order to
make something that feels authentic
um so you know sometimes when I've
designed things I'm like it's not quite
right it's probably because I'm not
sticking to the rules of of the
limitation of that technology
um
and so in this you had to design even is
I mean you had to design it so that it
looked like it was woven I imagined yeah
so yeah I mean I can show you some
details of it so the way that it's drawn
is basically in tiny lines yeah okay
um so you couldn't draw like solid
things I mean you probably haven't this
is probably the best yeah but you can
you can see the way I've actually drawn
in the woven lines in there
um
and yeah that again with with digital
printing it's something you have to do
um this is a picture of it when it's
installed in the set
um which again it doesn't look like this
in the film but
um and this that's how I did that carpet
as well so you know big consideration
with this is where does the bed go where
where is this um you know curtain going
you've got to make the images fit around
the architecture that's very important
um so but still you have the animals
kind of the animals with their yeah yeah
you know yeah so it's a similar theme
yeah it's a similar theme to the one
downstairs oh and just to say these
trees here they were kind of inspired by
the original
um 1959 animation
um
and here it is in the film so you can
see uh Aurora and the Queen and so the
Queen's embracing her but it's not
genuine
um and then you've got you know this is
her dress is pink and then I've got a
pink rose in the background because her
name's Briar Rose and then we've
obviously got this kind of chained
um spawn here yeah
um
which is obviously like a kind of
reflection of the narrative and that's I
mean I think that for people it's
important to see in how
subtle it is right because it and it
won't read consciously for people but
you know when you add up all these very
subtle Connections in a in a story
that's when people get a kind of magical
sense of coherence even though they're
not able to and that's what you know
like some of the symbolism that I point
out even like in Bible stories or in
myth or whatever uh
you know the the explicit links I point
out are perceived by people implicitly
people can perceive coherence they can
perceive they can perceive analogical
coherence even though they can't
explicate it they just know that the
story is good and they remember it but
they yeah so so like pointing it out is
fun for and it's wonderful because it
helps people see how these things are
built but uh someone would watch the
movie and get a sense of coherence
without if you pointed it out like you
said oh look at the same color of a
dress and the rose and then the the swan
in the background oh yeah okay that
makes sense uh but they don't even need
to see it for it to work yeah absolutely
right and whenever I meet people I've
seen films I've worked on I never want
them to have noticed my work because
because if they've noticed it probably
it's probably a bad thing you know the
what you want is just for people to come
out and say I really enjoyed the movie
you know that's what you want and you
don't want them to say I like that
tapestry in scene three
um because it again it really shouldn't
be detracting from the actors for
starters and secondly you don't want
that symbolism to be
you know to avert because you know it's
too much
um so yeah you like things kind of being
being hidden I'm it's nice to to hear
you say that you think they're subtle
because I always worry like why is that
too much but like you say I think most
people watching it probably wouldn't
notice no but I definitely know I mean
these are the things that I noticed but
I think most artists would have more
sensibility to to seeing that like I
said the work you did in Hellboy 2 I
just remember because it was it seemed
to me so rare that that this type of
detail was included in movies that it
just really stood out for me
um and the same I remember watching the
Bond film and it's and and the same just
feeling like it was so well done I mean
like everything was so beautiful not
beautiful not beautiful in the sense of
attractive but beautiful in the sense of
appropriate like all the scenes that
were appropriate yeah I think I think um
what you're saying is usually due to
having a really good director because
there's so many of us involved in the
process if you have a director like yamo
or Sam Mendes who really know what
they're doing they can really lead
everyone in One Direction
um and every if everyone knows what
they're doing it's great
um some some films I've worked on
haven't had that leadership and at that
point everyone's guessing and it can be
you can imagine the results
um well we've all seen like we've asked
you know and I hate to use specific
examples but I will uh you know this
recent series that this season the
series what it's called The Chosen the
Jesus series you know okay it's like
it you can see that there's no there's
no capacity to create coherent visual
spaces right it's like okay we need
something that looks old we need
something that looks Oriental like so we
just kind of put things in there and so
some of it is budget I totally
understand and I sympathize with that uh
but it affects your perception of the
story when you you know when you you
you're watching and there's no there's
no sense of coherence and then compare
that to for example watching Dune where
it it's not as if there's massive
amounts of story in Doom right it's it's
like it's actually a pretty slow film
but you're just so mesmerized by the
visual coherence of the story and the
attention to detail that it just it
traps you right you just keep watching
because it's so yeah yeah
it's interesting you say that because
um I've come to the end of my film work
now and I just wanted to chat to you
about something which is kind of what
how can we apply these these ideas in in
The Wider world and I've thought about
them a lot in terms of churches and how
churches are designed because of my
background whenever I go into a church
and I go into quite a lot here in
England
um I'm super sensitive to
so the way things are designed
um and you know ornament patterns
um that you know they're all
transmitting information basically to me
um and I've recently started going to a
new
um Romanian Orthodox Mission church and
I wanted to talk to you about it because
they're they're a new Mission their
circumstances are actually quite
compromised they're hiring a church from
the anglicans it's it's a big kind of
12th century Norman Church on a Hills
usual kind of setting in an English
Village
um and they're kind of coming in a few
days a week and setting up the you know
this this Orthodox Mission but the way
that they are they direct attention is
absolutely masterful and I and I I go in
and watch it and a lot of the Liturgy is
in Romanian but it doesn't matter
because what they're doing visually is
so captivating and they they basically
do it with color and light and for me
it's just an example that we can all
learn from of you actually don't need
the Hollywood budgets or you know the
huge resources because they don't
actually have very much but with what
they've got
they're just using it really cleverly
um and
I think happy to hear that by the way
because there are so many churches that
don't do that especially in America and
I have to say uh made closer to me than
I wish where there's a there's a desire
to to go over the top because like
almost overcompensate for the lack of a
good space and so it's like you know
buying ornaments at Home Depot and
gluing them on Plywood And then spray
painting it with gold paint and you
think man like you just do something
simple it would be so much better right
yeah so so what I see with this
particular Church which is so impressive
is they're investing in the things that
the congregation are witnessing close up
you know so it's like the um you know
the treasure binding of the Gospel
they've got the icons obviously and the
Chalice you know and then they got the
candelabras and pretty much that's it or
you know they're probably going to be
flowers and their icons are just on a
couple of easels but they've draped them
in some beautiful fabric
um and I and again I just love that
because it's economy and it's focus and
it's really putting the resources where
they should be and kind of traveling
around in England and going to churches
in other denominations what I see is
just you know in some ways they have
more resources but there isn't the same
Focus you know I mean might all be
fundraising for the the best free roof
or something which I I know these
practical problems exist and we need to
we need to address them but also it's
like but where is the priority
um and you know it's it's I really
wanted to if anyone's listening appeal
to people you know please please engage
artists and designers
um in your church
um because design is happening whether
you like it or not you know I think
you've talked about this Jonathan but
you know you can't avoid design it's
gonna work on your congregation anyway
so use it consciously and it doesn't
matter
you know whatever whatever your
expression of Christianity is it can be
done on different levels but but you
have to take care of it you know it's
like the Sky full stuff you know it look
it's simple but it still needs thinking
about yeah
um
yeah you I mean you can see the
you know in terms of in terms of
attention and design the it's
interesting to think about how
especially as many churches move towards
entertainment mode you know how the type
of design they use ends up reflecting
that and it's almost accidental they
don't necessarily realize what's going
on they just want to make something
interesting but the type of attention
that you give to a concert and the type
of attention you give to God is not the
same attention and so the the danger
like the danger of going bling right and
having light shows and smoke and all
that stuff is that there is a type of
attention the type that you talk about
which is like a simple candle on a table
and a you know a let's say just just a
bit of light coming in from a high
window that that has a transforming
effect that is
that's subtle but but has more to do
with the type of transformation we need
to
to do in our in ourselves like the type
of attention and transformation we need
to to to have then you know being
overwhelmed by uh on a massive sound
system and and uh and you know electric
guitars
absolutely yeah
right
um
all right and so this is this is this is
very this is like a big deal to me
because
um you know I the symbolic World
branding as some of you know I mean some
people some people were very attached to
it but it was it was done very rapidly
and with a bunch of different people and
and kind of chaotically in some ways and
so although I did like the image of Adam
and Eve uh there was something about it
which was too much it was it was too
much detail and everything so I've been
thinking about the desire to I've been
having the desire to create something
more simple more encompassing in terms
of
um you know it's weird like even this
image the symbolic world you know I had
these t-shirts printed I gave the
T-shirt to one of my kids and they're
like well I'm not gonna wear that dad
there's like naked people on the on the
image and I thought wait oh yeah that's
true I didn't even realize just how
there's there's a little too much in it
and so Heather contacted me and said you
know if you like the channel and then
she if I if I would like she would help
me to to kind of redesign some things
and so I was I was super excited because
I started working so we're going to take
you kind of through what our thinking
was and what we wanted to do so all
right you can you get you can go now
Heather this is this is exciting to me
okay and
right so the first thing to say is there
was already a logo which is really
important because
um
again there's an expectation from your
audience about what the symbolic world
is like whatever you say about that logo
it was established and so in very basic
terms I had to think about like what is
the atmosphere of the channel and from
what I remember about your intros it was
like a black World there was a kind of
glittering gold thing
um and it was there was quite a lot of
Dimension you know you've done some
quite cinematic stuff
so you know the danger is if I came
along with my ideas of like what I think
you should do and design something like
slick vector graphics like your audience
basically switches on the day that it
launches and they're like where are we
you know so
so you have to honor in the same way you
know with Mary Poppins or whatever you
have to honor what what is it kind of in
the hearts and minds of your audience
already and what are they used to and so
so you're evolving something you're not
kind of starting from scratch you're
going here's some elements that work
let's keep hold of them and let's kind
of build on them
so if I look at this logo here I
actually I really likes it
um but the main problem looking at that
technically for me is that all of the
kind of identity and detail was in the
back image and the lettering
um I I don't know I don't know how you
did that but I didn't do that that was
the people who made my website who just
like just put that up yeah okay so so
there hadn't been that much
consideration not much consideration at
all and you know that's your title and
it's a really brilliant title the
symbolic was it's like okay so we really
need to do something with the lettering
um and so at the hierarchy because again
problem is you've got thing in the
Forefront with no information really
it's a strange kind of 1980s white
typeface and then a thing at the back
has all the identities so we need to
flip those around and so it's just
working better
um so you came to me with this brief of
uh Norman Sicily and the paradexion tree
I think we can tell people a little bit
I just want to maybe tell people about
the peridexian tree and why what I
wanted to do with that because I know
some people are looking at the new logo
and wondering like what's going on with
the new logo so the peridex entry is a
medieval legend about a tree that exists
in the East it's a tree in India or it's
somewhere mysteriously in the East and
this tree is special because
under the tree there is a dragon that
that just kind of hangs out under the
tree and then there are doves that land
in the branches of this tree
um and while the doves are in the shadow
of the tree then the dragon won't harm
them you could even say that in some
ways the dragon protects them because
the dragon is scaring off any other
predator for the tree but as soon as the
as the dove leaves the the shadow of the
tree then the dragon will eat the bird
and so to me this was such a powerful
image of symbolism it contained Heaven
and Earth it contained this heavenly
influence that comes down on the
structure of of a patterned tree and
then the monster at the at the bottom
that is both a gargoyle but also the
monster that will devour the the pattern
if you're not careful and you and you
let these higher influences leave the
shadow of the pattern and so it just
seemed like a beautiful simple Cosmic
image that that had a lot of visual
potential to it as well
yeah
so it's a complex thing I think um you
know
it was challenging in lots of respects
because you have quite a long title and
what you'll usually see in Brands is if
you have a long title you have a very
simple image or you'll have a very a
complex image and a short title so I I
there is a lot to deal with here and
it's one of the things that
um I struggled with initially but so
normal system was amazing when you
showed me that it was kind of Mosaic
that I was aware of and I'd really
admired but I hadn't looked into it
deeply so I had the opportunity to do
that you know studied all those amazing
mosaics and knew there was like a lot of
visual potential in those
and these are like some of the first
sketches that I did
um and Looking Back Now they'd like
really over complicated and the main
reason for that is that I was just too
close to the reference what happens
quite often with historic references
that you kind of fall a bit in love with
it and and then you're too close to it
um and also I had a few iterations made
even before we started working where
there was a logo like this that
contained all the elements in it and you
know it looks good as like a you know
like as a tapestry or as uh you know
Andrew Gould looked at some of these and
said oh it looks like uh like a forged
gate you know something like that but
not a logo uh
yeah exactly that so they become almost
decorative and they would work as
decorative pieces but there's there's
too much information so again the
challenge was to really condense down
and like I said I had like a tree to
deal with I had dragons to deal with and
the doves so there's a lot of elements
um so we went through a few rounds and I
was like still it's still too much and I
think then you sort of said right we
need to sort of Go Back to Basics and
get into the world of the logo and here
was some kind of early
um attempts at that to really kind of
um
just condense down like what could a
tree be what is the minimal we could
show that could represent a tree and
what it you know in this case it's like
you know there's three strands and then
I've made the dragon just ahead yeah you
know I always tap the doves
um yeah and then we had the idea of
maybe if the doves if we show the doves
landing on the actual Dragon then that
sense of protection and danger could be
included into the into one image and at
first even without the tree we're like
maybe we just had to ditch the tree
because it's too much yeah yeah I think
we were having those conversations
aren't we going through like what how
how much can we get away with saying and
not saying I think
um but at this point I think you the
dragons seem to be the most important
thing and the the best
um emblem in terms of a kind of strong
logo that was that was memorable so I
think you I think this one was the one
that was closest but at this point
um I'm still using like off-the-shelf
types of typefaces and I knew that I
wasn't going to get away with that
because
um you know there literally isn't
anything from uh Norman Sicily in terms
of a typo
Sicily typeface what are designers
thinking it really doesn't exist like
nothing even close
so um so yeah I got to this stage I was
like right you know what I'm just gonna
Park the Dragon for a bit look at the
lettering and then I'm gonna come back
once I'm aware of what's gonna happen
with that
so in terms of the lettering I looked at
probably like 30 or something different
mosaics from frost you know Byzantine
architecture looked at um San Marco
um looked at Ravenna places like that
and really what you're looking at when
you when you when you look at this kind
of thing you're trying to find averages
so you're like you know you look at all
the S's and go what what's the kind of
tendency towards how they how they would
Express an S for example
um the other thing to say is when you're
drawing a typeface you
um you want it you want it to have some
of the idiosyncrasies of that historic
typeface but not too much because it it
has to work in the modern world so for
example you know so much some of these
letters you I would draw it accurately
and then and then I would kind of iron
it out so to speak to make it more kind
of commercial and feel
um
you're also looking for opportunities to
kind of inject
um other other kind of meanings and so
with the O I was aware that this shape
here you know is is in the icon of the
Transfiguration and this this sidewind
of Christ it seems to be a very
significant Shades in Christian art I'm
sure you know what's more about it than
I do so that that kind of gave me
um the idea of how I wanted to do the
O's
um and this is the this was the first
drawing in Black of um the typeface
uh and I once I'd done this I felt
pretty happy that I had lettering that
that was from that World
um
but like I said it's always a balance
between like the historic and then also
the commercial or the you know the
modern
um so I then started looking to you know
turn it into more of a brand and I just
I don't know how it happened just this
idea one day I just thought what if one
of the doves kind of was landing on the
eye and then I had the idea of you
having a little like tree like ligature
on the eye and I was looking at it I was
thinking you know this now has kind of
the imagery of the arc which I think is
kind of appropriate for what Jonathan's
doing so that kind of fitted as well
and the arc but it's it's also it's it
is the dove carrying the branch carrying
the pattern it's it's powerful but then
it's also referencing back to the
peridex entry in a subtle way right it's
not it's not as explicit but it's it has
it has the the bird landing on the tree
as well yeah so I was hoping that it
that it it answered the Paradox entry
brief but also it kind of had wider
associations for people because I don't
think you know you can look at a dove
without thinking of the flood narrative
I mean it's of course I'm sure most
people yeah I wouldn't even think of
that when they saw it but it's there
yeah
um and then I started looking at the
rendering so obviously wanted to go back
to the kind of the beautiful real uh
gold mosaics
um that I'd looked at in the reference
and
um and the other reason I I went for it
is because
um I knew that you'd probably want
something a bit dimensional like we
talked about in the beginning that you
know you've done things that are that
are quite cinematic and I know your
Channel's kind of famous for movie
interpretation so I was like what what
if I rendered it like you know a movie
title I've worked on a lot of films that
have that like metal type you know very
big at the moment so I thought yeah I
thought it kind of worked again it was
like historical but it also
um had a bit of kind of Pop Culture
about it as well
yeah um
and then to the dragon so this was my
final drawing of the Dragon
um and then adding the little Branch
inside the the circle too because we
kept struggling at how we're going to
include the tree and then you had this
idea of just like if we just had this
little branch and all of a sudden the
tree comes in without it being too
explicitly referenced yeah I actually
saw it on a Roman Mosaic and had they
had this little thing coming in and and
I was like okay that's how we do that so
again it's just gesturing isn't it
rather than having to explain the whole
thing
um
so yeah this this is the final dragon
and
um I was aware that in turn this is my
kind of concept for the website I was
awareness in the website you know we've
got these two elements that I was really
happy that the dragon is working on its
own as a symbol that that you'd be able
to use but in terms of the website we
might want to have two elements together
so again you're thinking about higher
Rock you've got the title and then the
dragon becomes a watermark so you know
as
for you as my client I'm trying to give
you as many different opportunities
because you've got many many kind of
applications you might be doing t-shirts
you know and so you're giving people a
kind of set of assets that they can then
adapt
so I felt like you know that that was
gonna
um kind of serve those purposes
um and yeah so this is the actual
website which is now live and looking
great I'm so pleased because it looks
exactly like um
yeah yeah it's perfect I think that it
does have that it does have a kind of
cinematic feel to it and there's also a
certain sobriety and simplicity even
though the the language like the letters
are are you know are flickering and
golden the basic Aesthetics of the
website is simple and the same with uh
like you're showing the uh the
thumbnails for the videos too uh Heather
kind of gave us a direction for the
thumbnails you know to to have simple
images with with simple text and then
have the Dragon Inside and I think that
the right that right mixture of kind of
Simplicity with the the very animated
logo is perfect for what we're doing
yeah so now everybody knows the mystery
of the of the new symbolic World logo
and so I mean I think what's great about
this is to is to see how you know in
some ways
like somebody would look at the logo now
and have no idea that it's based on a
peridexian tree but it but in some ways
it doesn't matter because the imagery is
there and the symbolism is there in the
title and in the in the uh it's its own
thing right it doesn't have to be
explicitly that but it eludes and it it
refers to to these types of images in a
way that makes the meaning implicit in
the image so it's like that's also kind
of how symbolism works sometimes we
think that you have to make references
explicit even in a story or in a movie
or or sometimes it's good to do that but
sometimes you don't have to you can just
have them as as being very implicit
analogies that don't have to be made to
try to make yourself look smart by
making them explicit you know yeah yeah
I'm a big fan of things that are
suggestive
um you know and I think yeah it's it's
ended up being really interesting I mean
one thing I forgot to say about the
dragon is
um the way that I designed it I really
wanted it to be like a real hybrid
creature you know it's like the the the
wing is feathered
you know it's not like a standard dragon
wing but one of the challenges was I
looked into
um uh the Norman Sicily and you can't
really find any dragons in that world
they're they're much more like Griffins
because that world was looking much more
towards Islamic Art and the East and and
those influences and we looked at like
Mesopotamian dragons and things like
that so it was always going to be a
hybrid Dragon
um and so yeah that I had the feathered
wing and then you know the tail is
almost like a sea serpent so there was
it's almost like kind of three creatures
stuck together
um which
is it's perfect it's more like because
the the dragon and I think that's one of
the things we were butting up against is
that the dragon in Western thinking is
so tired in some ways like infant in
fantasy it has become so tired that you
know proposing more of a a kind of
Griffin Dragon
uh is still the same idea as the dragon
it's the same thing uh but it has a it
has a freshness to it that that makes
you
makes you notice it differently than if
it was if it look if it would if we'd
use the medieval Dragon then it would
have been it would have been like
Dungeons and Dragons it would have been
all these images of Game of Thrones and
all these types of things would have
been rising up to people's minds and
that's not what we wanted so yeah
because I think in modern day medieval
films are showing dragons in a
particular way that we're all used to as
you described like leathery Wings maybe
their scales but if you look at the um
dragons in manuscripts they're really
weird you know some of them have only
got two legs like this one and then so I
wanted to go back to the really weird
dragons you know the really like you say
hybrid hybrid dragons
um and and try and use that because if
you don't have a direct reference you
really have to kind of pull from
different sources
um so yeah I hope it's kind of
uh unusual in that way
so so Heather thank you so much and I
want to make the everybody most people
probably know that are watching this but
uh some those who don't know yet Heather
and I have been working on other
projects uh we're going to publish a
version of Snow White that she
Illustrated completely and that I wrote
and that I am it's the thing that I'm
the most excited about that I'm doing
right now it's really amazing uh Heather
just finished up all the illustrations
they're they're beautiful and powerful
and and have all this Rich complexity in
terms of suggesting and symbolism so I'm
I'm looking forward to to introducing
that to you we're going to have another
conversation in a few weeks that are
going to be talking about Snow White and
the choices that we made both in terms
of story and in terms of illustration so
I'm I'm definitely looking forward to
introducing all that and and yeah and
and continuing to work with Heather so
Heather thanks for your time and thanks
for all your Creative Energy you're very
welcome thank you